wenn ich heute noch ein glückliches paar
sie werde ich wahnsinnig jena riesa naja
jetzt verstehe ich warum du mein anrufer
in weggedrückt hat beschäftigt lena ich
freue mich so für dich und du darfst
nicht nach sao paulo geben niemals
vergisst
die models schon gut ich hatte jo
erzählt dass ich überlege lehrerinnen
auslandsschule zu werden aber keine
panik
lena muss vorher noch studieren und das
dauert auch seine zeit entspannt ist
aber was ist mit seiner schauspielerei
ich dachte ich weiß auch nicht was
klappt einfach nie
manchmal glaube ich ich habe kein talent
natürlich hast du talent zumindest mir
als ich sonst hätte ich mich gestern
carla gegenüber cooler verhalten
ich glaube du hast etwas in den falschen
hals bekommen meint ich hab da was
falsch verstanden was kann man an einer
halbnackten frau die in meiner küche
sitzt falsch verstehen
also ich weiß nicht ob mark und carla
tatsächlich also als wir nach hause
kamen sah es nicht so aus als ob man
wirklich interesse an carla hätte du
warst doch nicht die ganze zeit dabei
oder
ich hab sie doch eben schon mal gesagt
vielleicht ist ihr unrecht muss jetzt
leider los ist gleich noch einen termin
im café tut mir leid
bis 3 schön dass du da